Is there anything more nerve wracking than speaking in public
on a panel in front of thousands of people?
For me personally, there isn't.
And I spent all night tossing and turning cause I felt so anxious
but also very excited.
When business of fashion invited us to London to speak,
I obviously could not say no.
Think there's something so powerful about being intentional
about how and when you use your voice.
So this panel felt like the perfect environment for me
and lucky to sit down and have a conversation about our journey,
why we do what we do, our individual careers,
and everything that comes with it.
But before that, we were in mom and dad mode
wanting to unwind
and took whimsy on a little bike ride around the property
to see all the little animals.
Since it was a lot colder than we anticipated,
we decided to head back early
and drop her off at the cabin with my brother,
who came all the way from Germany to watch her,
which I always appreciate so much.
This point I realized that it was 2:00,
so we headed over to the barn all mic'd up and did a quick sound check,
and I was so nervous at this point
that I needed a hot cup of tea to calm me down.
Rehearsals were still going strong at this point,
so we took a seat and watched them all.
Not long after that, the talk started
and Hearing stories about perseverance
overcoming the most difficult circumstances made me so emotional,
and I tried not crying off my makeup,
but then it was our turn to speak.
Once I got on that panel, all my nerves disappeared,
and it was the most beautiful experience.